il aime buzzati stéphanie chouinard luc
ferrandez bonsoir bon alors on en a on
va voir des images en direct
actuellement on en a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup parlé la semaine dernière avant
que ça survienne pilotes évidemment
cette danger d analyse quand c'est pas
arrivé on était rendus ou c'est janvier
américain à sous sur le parlement bien
préparés au pire vous allez me dire la
police c'est son travail mais le pire
hélène tour de table là dessus d'eux
n'est pas arrivé quoique on va voir les
images quand même alors il ya eu des
scènes disgracieuses ya eu bien sûr des
groupes on le voyait visuellement à eux
des drapeaux nazis un banc mais de façon
générale et l'inde samedi c'est plutôt
des gens qui avaient envie de se
retrouver puis diront il y en a trop de
mesures exactes je suis pas allé me
promener samedi mais je suis allé me
promener aujourd'hui alors je veux juste
que commencer mais poteau par ça mais
oui j'allais me promener et ce qu'ont
constaté c'était surtout cette question
de la ségrégation selon le statut
vaccinal je trouve que c'est l'élément
qui revenait le plus souvent mais mais
vous l'avez bien dit les yeux
une constellation de récriminations face
à la pandémie le tisseur groupe là bas
mais beaucoup autour de cette
ségrégation c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui remet beaucoup mais will
l'environnement il est bon enfant les
gens sont au sol peu à la fête et
j'aimerais quand même apporter une
précision parce que certains politiciens
disait aujourd'hui qui était le jour du
retour du parlement après le long congé
des fêtes c'est pas vrai qu'on va se
laisser intimider c'est pour ça qu'on
est ici au parlement pour démontrer que
ça nous empêche pas d'être ici mais la
réalité le sait que les manifestants
sont même pas proche des portes mais ils
sont derrière évidemment la clôture
d'enceinte mais même dans les portes de
cette clôture il n'ya pas
d'agglomération de dagris tin man de
manifestations
il ya rien par rapport à cela l'accès au
parlement qui se passe stéphanie
commentaire général la fin de semaine
parce qu on est passé d'un extrême à
l'autre on est passé de l'analyse 6
janvier sont sur le capitole au scénario
peut-être trop bon enfant de samedi
oustalé qu'alain tout le monde était bon
peut-être la vérité est un peu entre les
deux c'est plus complexe où
effectivement ça a été de manifestations
qui a été très majoritairement pacifique
avec des éléments bon qui ont voulu être
quand même dérangeant les gens qui
habitent au centre-ville d'ottawa et
commence à en agacer quand même du bruit
en particulier qui est qui est constant
jour et nuit il n'y a pas eu de casse
mais il ya quand même eu certains
comportements déplorables et j'ai pas
besoin de les répéter donc effectivement
on n'est pas dans un dans un scénario du
6 janvier mais on savait déjà avant que
les gens arrivent qui allait y avoir des
éléments plus dérangeant parmi les
organisateurs et ça s'est avéré des
drapeaux nazis des drapeau confédéré qui
sont loin du mandat qui était le message
qui se voulait principal c'est à dire
cesser le mandat sanitaire on le voit le
drapeau confédéré entre autres qui est
devenu enfin fera pas toute l'histoire
du drapeau confédéré mais notre impôt
sudiste qui est devenue symbole aussi
qui peut être un symbole qui peut être
un symbole raciste fort il ya eu un
monument bon ça c'est terry fox convoi
qui a été barbouillée et il ya eu la
tombe du soldat inconnu
le cénotaphe que nous on a uriné tout ça
donc le qui a eu il ya eu compte tenu du
nombre peu de gestes de gracieux mais y
en a eu quand même votre votre compte
rendu de la fin de semaine a voulu mais
si elle veut parallèle à faire avec le 6
janvier c'était le fait que c'est une
coalition de groupes qui n'est pas juste
juste là pour
la vaccination des gens qui ont dans le
passé revendiqué tour de chauffe entier
totti taxation à ces migrations mais le
parallèle s'arrête là moi j'ai toujours
partie qui peut pas avoir le même niveau
de violence que c'est charvier pour la
bonne raison que il n'y en a pas de
violence immanente qui précèdent
l'événement aux etats unis les onze
keeper pis les cowboys ont été dans des
manifestations où il et coup de feu dans
les manifestations blattmann a eu des
américains qui sont sortis avec leurs
armes pour défendre la ville entre
guillemets et ça on voit pas ça au
canada alors la violence ça serait vente
pas comme ça à partir de l'herbe il faut
qu'il y ait un climat de violence et le
climat de violence il n'est pas le même
au canada qu'aux états unis on va
écouter monsieur trudeau monsieur
deltell et monsieur du m1 qui ont à leur
façon analyser tout ça en ligue 1
je comprends qu'il ya certaines
personnes qui choisissent de rejeter la
science qui choisissent de rejeter
l'entr'aide mais c'est leur choix les
défis auxquels on est en train de faire
face dans nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement sont pas dus à au
politique de vaccination mais sont dues
à la coved 19 c pan os pétanque on va
finir cette pandémie
c'est en se faisant vacciner
ces gens là ont joué et jouent ils vont
continuer à jouer un rôle important et
c'est pas les méprisants puis en faisant
l'amalgamé entre les imbéciles qui ont
commis les gestes et rires
irrévérencieux dont je parlais tantôt et
les travailleurs canadiens honnête qui
veulent avancer la situation qu'on va
améliorer la situation bien au contraire
premier ministre provoque les gens et ça
pour nous c'est très très dommageable
tant pour la
situation actuelle mais surtout pour
l'unité qu'on doit avoir
il ya plusieurs de leurs revendications
que j'appuie je l'aï dit publiquement et
je le répète ici aujourd'hui
et si les camionneurs sont rendus dans
la rue aujourd'hui à faire un convoi
c'est parce que on a des remparts dans
notre démocratie qui devait défendre
justement d'un système démocratique qui
devait défendre nos droits civiques qui
ont lamentablement échoué
je pense notamment à des fédérations des
regroupements de gens d'affaires le
barreau les tribunaux les défenseurs des
droits civiques qui est très peu de gens
qui se sont levés par rapport à la
dérive que le québec a subi depuis deux
ans
alors autre tour de table c'est une
chose dire il ya trop de mesures sans
terre on peut le plaider en démocratie
se comparer à d'autres pays dit rien de
plus ici et cetera mais c'est une autre
chose hélène que de dire mais le virus
existent pas puis je vais pas me mettre
du poison dans le bras c'est celui qui
rend cette soupe la complexe à analyser
ces sauf que c'est difficile de défendre
des gens qui prétendent que le vaccin
était ni contaminés on veut ça fait de
nous des rats de laboratoire
je comprends tout à fait mais il faut
reconnaître que monsieur trudeau joue un
jeu politique ici un jeu que je pense à
être dangereux il le fait depuis le
début c'est à dire qu'il a constaté que
d'être du côté de des propres aux
mesures sanitaires mur à mur c'est plus
populaires parce qu'une forte majorité
des canadiens qui sont de ce côté là et
de renvoyer tous les autres qui sont le
moindrement en désaccord dans le cas des
obscurantistes et des anti science comme
il le fait c'est gagnant politiquement
mais ce faisant il polarise l'échiquier
politique et c'est dangereux
certains commentateurs avaient fait un
lien entre ce qu'on voit et le tropisme
moi je vois le lien ailleurs je vois je
me rappelle aux états unis comment les
médias se sont moqués de trompes comment
madame clinton a parlé de ceux qui
appuyaient monsieur tron comme des
déplorable et finalement tous ces gens
là se sont trouvés et bt de voir que cet
homme monsieur tromper devenu président
il est là le problème quand on cesse
d'écouter l'autre quand on perd notre
empathie on perd notre capacité
d'altérité et on ne se comprend plus est
ce qu'on voit pu moorea être une
occasion d'inciter davantage mais pour
l'instant c'est parce qu'on constate
trop de la part de monsieur top de
trudeau certainement oui parce que
stéphane est un lieu qu'on l'a vu
monsieur trudeau n'a pas parce que
monsieur legault a tendu la main
on en parlera de sa main la personne qui
a nommé pour marie victorin mais il a
peu tendu la main en sentant qu'il
fallait pas non plus il y avait beaucoup
de monde stéphanie luxe n'est pas tous
des illuminés un d'extrême droite alors
est ce que monsieur trudeau devrait à
votre avis
faire un pas aussi payant politiquement
de ne pas faire ce poste et fanny et
comme elle aime le dit tantôt et son le
voyait déjà durant les élections parce
que monsieur trudeau parle de la
pandémie ou des mesures sanitaires
s'adresse toujours à la majorité sans
s'adresser à la minorité même si parmi
la minorité se sont certainement pas
tous des complotistes ya des questions
qui sont très valide à poser sur les
boisements sur la la le droit sobczak
pris de façon de fonctions notamment
saviez avec certaines restrictions mais
ça veut pas dire que ce sont tous des
complotistes que les gens d'extrême
droite mais monsieur trudeau ne fait pas
ni en cela est effectivement ça fait de
la division et c est ça pose d'autres
problèmes pour des parlementaires qui
souhaiteraient tendre la main fois parmi
leurs électorats des gens qui se posent
encore des questions sur les mesures
sanitaires ou qui en ont simplement
ras-le-bol ou qui économiquement sont en
situation difficile actuellement mais on
n'a pas l'impression de way luc si c'est
la différence entre écouter quelqu'un
dire je pas d'accord tu devrais vaccin
pour teinter les régions où le regard
des deux indiens tu comprends ma part
oui sauf que la situation de ce taux est
très compliqué parce qu'il fait face au
parti conservateur le parti conservateur
s'est pas gêné ou non plus pour
politiser le dossier avec des appuis de
plusieurs députés par exemple à des
déclarations que très très large sur le
refus du projet de la vaccination mais
sur le refus des mesures sanitaires etc
il ya un temps dans la gouvernante on
gouverne j'imagine où il faut mettre son
poing sur la table et dire j'ai de
l'empathie j'ai de la compassion je
comprends mais il faut se faire vacciner
et il faut
respecter les mesures on peut pas juste
dire je vous comprends il faut dire je
vous comprends mais nous sommes à
l'époque où il va falloir que tout le
monde fasse un certain respect des
mesures et les mesures sont parfois
contradictoires les mesures sont parfois
mal expliqué le gouvernement n'est pas
blanc comme neige les communicateurs
sont pas blancs comme neige mais faut
les respecter il lui donna login il est
à la tête de soul de ce mouvement le
temps de faire respecter des mesures
alors moi je lui donne ma compréhension
du moins je comprends la situation dans
laquelle se trouvent bon l'autre
question que sa peau je le disais on ne
parlait de la fin de semaine débordement
un peu mais dans l'ensemble non mais la
ln combien de temps parce que vous avez
entendu le commerçant de boucler une
province lui un peu plus dû couper le
souffle et que les restaurateurs avaient
manifesté envoyer les russies puis ça
finit plus vous nous empêcher de vivre
la ville d'ottawa ne peut pas de
paralyser pendant deux semaines ils
n'ont effectivement il ya beaucoup
d'agacement da par des résidents et on
les comprend une manifestation au cette
manifestation est très dérangeant que
vous aviez mentionniez tout en émission
que combien d'essence sont utiles parce
que je pense que c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé il y aurait éventuellement des
pannes sèches qui va amener les gens à
quitter mais oui la question se pose et
moi je vais oser un parallèle quand même
rappelons nous il ya deux ans a
quasiment pareille date le pays était
paralysé par les blocages de chemin
ferrée par des autochtones et où leurs
alliés un peu à travers le pays et ça
aussi ça avait perturbé les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
savez à empêcher les gens d'aller
travailler dans certaines villes parce
que leurs trains de banlieue ne voulait
plus et monsieur trudeau n'avait pas
voulu pour des raisons que l'on
comprenne aussi explosé fetch hétéro
mais n'avait pas demandé aux gens de
plier bagages avant deux semaines il
faut quand même voir le parallèle que
ici dans la situation qui nous intéresse
il leur demandait dès aujourd'hui allez
vous en alors que la dernière fois il
avait été capable d'attendre une 14ème
deux jours vous êtes ont été plus
patient que le watsu athènes qui
bloquaient les
une voie ferrée stéphanie parce que
politiquement ça va se poser la pression
va monter en même temps c'est pas facile
de déloger des 18 roule non et puis bon
pour venir sur la crise dit wait your
turn je dirais on a été plus patient oui
mais non parce qu'il ya quand même eu
des altercations avec les forces
policières assez rapidement là où il y
avait des blocus ferroviaire et
d'ailleurs on était plusieurs personnes
a remarqué le deux poids deux mesures de
certaines manifestations qui ont déjà eu
lieu au centre-ville d'ottawa et la
façon dont le corps policier d'ottawa
traite cette manifestation là depuis le
début de la fin de semaine on sait que
le chef de police lolli en tenter
d'expliquer les raisons derrière
lesquels il a utilisé les mesures qui
ont été mises en place en fait de même
mais ça reste ça a laissé les résidents
d'ottawa avec beaucoup de questions je
pense vous dit qu'on est plus patient
avec des avec des membres de la majorité
certainement on a même vu circuler des
photos où le corps de police d'ottawa et
le corps de sécurité parlementaire
semblait sympathisé avec avec les
manifestants prendre des photos avec
avec des pouces en l'air et c'est alors
qu'on a déjà vu les mêmes corps de
police est beaucoup moins patients
vis-à-vis d'autres manifestants qui
étaient tout aussi pacifique comme comme
par exemple adorno mort comme par
exemple occupants et
comme d'autres qui ne la croix de
mareuil par exemple qui ont pris les
devants du parlement à un certain nombre
de reprises de façon tout à fait
pacifique mais où la réponse des corps
de police étaient beaucoup plus musclé
le coma que pu faire la police comment
comment le politique peut gérer seul
parce qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
monde qu'il ya une rue comme une rue que
dis-je tout un cadre il était requis par
west quercy mais moi je suis d'accord
avec mes deux collègues le dal kodock
par toutes les villes montréal new york
et ses relents de ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a attendu le mouvement perdent la
plupart de ces manifestants qui reste un
gros assez marginal de personnes et là
on évoque les questions de sécurité et
les questions de sécurité pour soi sont
réels des questions de sécurité pour
toujours mais souvent pour dire là il ya
danger que vous restiez là encore par
exemple si on décide que des enfants
doivent passer leur pour aller sur le
chemin de l'école à temps plein ou s'il
ya eu des altercations des ambulances
c'est comme ça qu'ils peuvent agir
effectivement de dire le centre-ville
est occupé et c'est inacceptable
eh bien il ya eu plein de manifestations
inacceptable balle passée on peut pas
gérer une manifestation sur la base de
ses opinions sur les messages véhiculés
dans la manifestation faut la gérer sur
l'eau des questions de sécurité bon
c'est quand même complet que je le dise
elle parce qu'ils prennent beaucoup de
place
marie-victorin hier monsieur legault a
présenté celle idriss man qu'on va voir
à l'instant une ex vice présidente de la
fiq c'est intéressant qui a été très
critique envers le gouvernement le
groupe et à négocier donc cas pas la
langue dans sa poche on va entendre
monsieur legault et sur le racisme et
qu'elle dit mais bien sûr que ça existe
mais elle a décidé de pas s'enfarger
dans l'emoa dis je elle a fait le pari
qu'à l'intérieur on pouvait changer les
choses si elle est élue bien sûr on
l'écouté on écoute on est comme monsieur
legault l on revient
il ya des gens qui vont être surpris
parce que jusqu'à tout récemment
depuis quatre ans chirurgie était vice
président de l'afe donc c'est possible
qu'avec timmins vous trouviez des traces
de d'endroits où on n'était pas toujours
d'accord donc c'est très bien venu
d'avoir quelqu'un comme celle pour venir
aider notre équipe
j'ai dit des choses je les assume
totalement
mais l'ouverture est là puis il n'y a
pas de consensus sur la définition c'est
normal on est dans une société avec
différentes opinions mais l'important
c'est de lutter contre le racisme et le
gouvernement il est prêt alpha
tour de table très rapide un luxe
d'abord
ailier c'est un grand coup pour monsieur
legault parce que il dit voter pour
nouveauté pour madame de simone et ça va
être un vote pour le changement alors
que vraisemblablement voter pour le
gouvernement
gros coup de la part de la cac stéphanie
ouais c'est une grosse pointure on sent
qu'on veut déloger le parti québécois
qui étant celle de marie victorin depuis
des décennies donc ce sera intéressant
si madame de heureusement n'était lui
devoir de ne pas qu'elle porte elle
héritera c'est l'italie et jusqu'à quel
point on pourra changer les choses de
l'intérieur ça tu pleurais tellement
intéressante à chéméré moi je dis bravo
quand même à cette dame qui nous
rappelle que les partis politiques ne
sont forts monolithique on a le droit
d'avoir des diversités d'opinion à
l'intérieur eh oui c'est comme ça que
les parties évolue quand il ya des six
éléments dissidents qui déjà est il
faudrait qu'on change de fusion alors
bravo et elle lance en est pas caché son
est bien défendu chapeau comme seule
voie de l'intérieur vouloir changer les
choses a dit sida ça ça met de la
richesse dans les débats démocratiques
merci à vous trois très gentil au revoir
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh